so there are situations where you have
some type of a function this is a
clearly a non-linear function f of x is
equal to 1 over x minus 1. this is its
graph or at least part of its graph
right over here but where you want to
approximate it with a linear function
especially around a certain value and so
what we're going to do is we want to
find an approximation let me write this
down i want to find
an approximation
for and actually let me clear i want to
find a linear approximation so i'm going
to approximate it with a line
i want to find a linear
approximation
of f
around
and you need to know where you're going
to be approximating it around x equals
negative 1. so what do we mean by that
well let's look at this graph over here
on this curve when x is equal to
negative 1 f of negative 1 is
negative is
negative one-half which sticks us right
over there let me do this in a
better color so it's right over there
and what we want to do is approximate it
with a line around that
and what we're essentially going to do
is we're going to approximate it with
the equation of the tangent line the
tangent line is going to look something
something like
that
and as we can see as we get further and
further from from x equals negative one
the approximation gets worse and worse
but if we stay around x equals negative
one well it's a decent it is a as good
as you can get for a linear
approximation or at least in this case
example is a very good linear
approximation so when people say hey
find a linear approximation of f around
x equals negative one or if they say
what is the following is the best
approximation and all of your choices
are our lines well essentially they're
asking you to find the equation of the
tangent line at x equals negative 1. so
let's do that so in order to find the
equation of the tangent line the
equation of a line is y is equal to mx
plus b where m is the slope and b is the
y-intercept there's other ways that you
could think about it you could think
about it in terms of point-slope where
you could say
y
minus
some y that sits on that line is equal
to the slope times x minus the
corresponding x1 so x1 comma y1 sits on
that line someplace and actually i like
to write this point slope form like this
sometimes y minus y1
over
x minus x1 is equal to b because this
comes straight out of the idea of look
if x1 and y1 are on the line
the slope between any other point on the
line and that point is going to be your
slope of your line so we could think
about it any any of these ways so let's
first find the slope of the tangent line
and that's where the derivative is
useful so f well actually let me just
write f of x again so i'm going to write
it as x minus 1 to the negative 1 power
because that makes it a little bit
clearer that we can use the power rule
and a little bit of the chain rule
so the derivative of f with respect to x
is equal to so the derivative of x minus
1 to the negative 1 with respect to x
minus 1 well that's just going to be
we're just going to use the power rule
here it's going to be negative 1
times
x minus 1 to the negative 2 and then
we're going to multiply that times the
derivative of x minus 1 with respect to
x
well that's just going to be 1 right the
derivative of x with respect to x is 1
derivative of negative 1 with respect to
x is 0. so we could say times 1 here if
we like
or we could just not write that because
it doesn't change the value and so let's
evaluate that when x is equal to
negative 1.
so
f prime
of negative 1 is equal to i could just
write this as negative all right look
this way negative 1 over
negative
minus 1
squared
and so this is going to be negative 2
down here
so this is equal to negative
negative 1 4.
so the slope of our tangent line
is so i could write this way m is equal
to negative
negative 1 4.
and so now we just have to write its
equation down
so we already know an x1 and a y1 that
sits on the line in fact we want to use
the point when x equals negative 1. so
we know that the point
negative 1
comma we could just
and put it right over here f of negative
1 is
negative one-half one over negative one
minus one negative one-half
so we know that this negative one
comma negative one-half that that is on
our curve and it is on our line that's
the point at which the tangent and the
curve actually intersect and so we can
use any of these to now write the
equation of our line we could say
y i'll do it right here y minus y one
so minus
negative one-half
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to our slope
negative one-fourth i'm just using the
point-slope version of our equation is
equal to our slope times
x minus x1 so x minus our x coordinate
that we know sits on this
so minus negative 1. and so let me now
write all of this in a neutral color
this will be y
plus one half is equal to
and i can so this is going to be plus 1
right over there so i can distribute the
negative 1 4. so it's negative 1 4 x
minus 1 4
minus 1 4 and then i can subtract one
half from both sides so i'm going to get
y is equal to negative 1 4 x
and then if i already am subtracting 1
4th and i subtract another half that's
going to be negative three fourths
so minus three
minus three fourths so and that's
actually pretty close to what i drew up
here this should be intersecting the y
axis at negative
three fourths so there you have it this
this
line or you could even say this this
equation is going to be a very good
linear approximation about as good as
you can get for a linear approximation
for that non-linear function around x
equals negative 1. you might say well
why didn't they just ask me
to find the equation of the tangent line
at x equals negative 1 well they could
have but there's a little bit of extra
cognitive processing here where you say
okay i can actually use the equation of
the tangent line at to approximate this
function around x equals negative 1.